boxes that it raises i i think that's
potentially more plausible
um but my i should i should stress that
the agnosticism the agnostic atheism
that i currently
possess is quite unlike the one that i
had maybe four years ago beforehand it
was very much the case
that i essentially would have said like
there aren't really any good reasons to
think that god exists
or at least those reasons that have been
put forward i think don't work
now and that is to say i was sat on the
fence
um because there was just there was just
no breeze there was just no breeze to
push me onto one side
one side i was just sat there um now
i'm still sad on the fence i'm still an
agnostic atheist of some description
but now it's more like there are equally
uh
beautiful breezes pushing in opposite
directions right so i do
think that uh the contingency argument
for the existence of god is a strong one
i do think that
certain ontological arguments you know
if there are certain quarrels like the
one we're having now can be
resolved like is is a good argument is
at least a good attempt
to prove the existence of god um i think
that the idea of an infinite regress
probably does lead to unacceptable
paradoxes and so
i would say that on its own yes
like it's a it's a i think there's good
reason to think that there is a
necessary unmoved mover
however now the agnosticism is that
that's the breeze pushing in one
direction
uh but there's also now i've i've been
more
um uh i've i've thought a lot more and a
lot more deeply about the breezes that
would go in the opposite direction
involving the problem of evil or divine
hiddenness or animal suffering in
particular and these kinds of things
the potential paradox is involved in the
necessary being arguments about modal
fatalism for instance that we were just
talking about
that now pushed me in the other
direction so on its own yeah i do i do
i do find more plausible on a surface
level
um the idea of a necessary unmoved mover
than the idea of an infinite regress of
causes
if you asked about it in isolation
as you guys saw there cosmic has come to
a good realization i believe
which shows criticality possibly
sincerity shows open-mindedness on his
behalf
that uh you know there are good reasons
to believe in things like the
contingency argument which as
many of you know i've written a book
about i'm doing my phd about
because i personally believe it's it's
something which is really it's
inescapable the conclusion of it is
inescapable almost it's irrefutable i
believe and it's been around
uh forms of it have been around for for
thousands of years it's been around
since the hellenistic period
and then it's been kind of revamped by
avicenna
and then it was uh taken again by thomas
aquinas and maimonides and musabi
and it was taken again by leibniz and
different forms has been
elaborated upon and uh spoken about by
different thinkers and
in my estimation it's it's the least
refuted argument for god's existence yes
there are other arguments
that have been used and these are kalam
cosmological arguments
and different types of calam
cosmological arguments of course i've
written a book called
cosmological arguments if you guys are
interested and of course
in this in the debate i had of course
mick i brought the contingency argument
up now unfortunately you know
we we couldn't really get anything from
him as to
by way of a refutation of the argument
now we know he actually sees it as
actually quite powerful argument
which is good i'm happy that he's come
to this conclusion it shows it shows
maturity on his behalf educational
maturity i really hope he doesn't change
his mind on this and
because that will show instability in uh
in process and
cognitive processes that one day you
believe in this and that you know and
that they believe in that
i really hope that he sticks to his guns
on this and he doesn't change his mind
on his at least
his classification of design um and also
i would say well done
well done to him good man that you've
done that the things that he's actually
mentioned
um in terms of things that are pushing
him in the other direction
on his analogy or his uh language some
the breeze that pushes the other way
things like divine heightenedness or our
hiddenness
and um you know the problem of evil
obviously it's been spoken about at
length
we have um videos on it you can put my
name on youtube and put
for example the problem of evil i've
spoken about it at length and what is
evil does it even exist on
the atheistic paradigm does it even
exist from the materialistic paradigm
um you know and so on
what does it mean to to say well does
evil exist does that disprove
in god we've had these conversations of
course these are secondary
considerations in my opinion these are
secondary considerations once you've
established
the reality of a necessary existence
this is more powerful than anything else
and the fact that he's been able to do
this is really really good and he's one
step closer to the ultimate truth and i
really encourage him to do that
to move in that direction maybe what he
said would not have been well received
uh with with his people and this the
people supporters and you know
subscribers and so on but i i really
acknowledge that this is a brave step
forward and i hope we continue taking
these brave step forwards well done to
him
um the other thing divine hiddenness or
the fact that god is hidden from the
people
why is he so hidden this is something
obviously we as muslims don't believe
and we believe that
that every human being is born on the
predisposition and believing in god
and this is something i've mentioned
this i think even the debate i mentioned
but i want to remind everyone of it
it's the uh the or the predisposition is
something which has good
evidence by way of anthropological
evidence and sociological evidence so
for example justin barrett
who in 2011 part of the oxford
anthropological society
uh spoke about us having an innate
receptivity to believing in god and
you know he done these the study that
children before socialization
that there's something which is kind of
um corresponds across culture
cross-culturally uh among children which
is that children do have this
receptivity
in his words uh in a a receptivity to
believing in a higher being
and i say that this is this is evidence
to the contrary of
um which can be juxtaposed with the idea
of uh
hide-and-seek
that's one thing aside i wanted to
continue thinking about these things and
obviously animal rights or something
which we as muslims
we very much we very much respect
there's a hadith of a woman who's a
prostitute okay
that she gave a dog water and according
to that she was forgiven for her sins
for doing that
just because she gave a dog water even
though she's defiled herself
in the most disgusting way possible by
living
not the most disgusting way possible
doing that would be to be a polytheist
but in a very damning way but that she
gave that dog
water would put her in a among the
people that are forgiven as a dog
and we believe that the day of judgment
is a forum where in which all of these
kinds of
injustices that have been done to
animals will be kind of um
adjusted and in fact that is the day of
recompense and we have a beautiful
hadith
um that talks about the two goats one of
them horned goat and the other one is
not horned
and the one that attacked one horned
goat the attack the other goat without
horns
will now get its retribution so
everything will be
fully uh and yeah it's true like what we
see today and obviously we don't come to
vegan conclusions
but we see today by way of uh animal
suffering so like
we we think that that is against the sun
against islam you know the
cutting the beaks off the chicken and
suffocating them and so on
this is if the prophet was around he
would surely have
uh have have negated and
refuted that kind of thing uh especially
when we have hadith to that effect for
example the woman who's
who um was torturing her cat okay and
she went to hell
for that or she we know that she's gonna
go to hell for that because she
what kind of person does it take to
really torture another innocent creature
like a cat
so yeah animal rights are important uh
divine hiddenness if you think of it in
you know in contra in contra distinction
with the fetal you'll realize
that the fethra of the predisposition is
actually something which is super
rational and um
precedes any rational argumentation
which is why i was thinking about this
this verse in the quran which is a
really beautiful verse
and it came about in and i thought about
pondering over it it was a
verse that said uh
you know if you're in any doubt as to
the religion of islam
my religion the prophet muhammad's
religion not just his religion but the
religion of moses and abraham and jesus
and those as well then i don't worship
other gods that you that are worshiped
aside from god but i worship god who
who brings us like who who takes away
our lives and takes away our souls and
takes away our consciousness
this is such a powerful thing because
really if you look at the six
major world religions in the world today
you'll find that islam is the only one
with the conception of god which is also
not only only natural but rational as
well
this is the reality like we don't
believe in a man god we don't believe
it's conceivable or intelligible
or acceptable to believe that there's
any part any human being is
is is god because it necessitates
contradictions in terms we don't believe
in an animal god we don't believe in a
man god
you see what i mean and so you've
already stricken off
christianity we've already stricken off
hinduism a pantheistic notion of it
we've already stricken off fantastic
notions of sikhism
uh so what are we left with we're left
with judaism
right which is a very um exclusivist
faith what we left with right
not much buddhism which is not even a
faith really in that sense
uh so what we say therefore is keep
looking
not just to him but to his followers as
well keep looking keep being
critical and you'll come to this
conclusion but just one more thing be
spiritual as well if there is a
necessary existence
then think of one thing what
relationship are we meant to have with
this necessary existence
what relationship are we meant to have
and the answer we give is as follows
the relationship we are meant to have
with the necessary existence is the
relationship of submission
everything else in creation is
submitting to the will of the necessary
existence
we must do the same if we do the same we
will be at one with nature in the
sense of the word which is acceptable uh
you know which is which makes sense
because we'll be doing everything we'll
be doing things which everything else in
creation is doing which is submitting to
the laws of the law maker
and so think think think and i would ask
i would ask everyone really if
just make supplication because we
believe as muslims
the quran says
and if my slaves doesn't say the muslims
if my slaves ask about me then i am near
and i answer the caller of the call when
he calls so call
on to god and ask him to guide you
because believe me
believe you me if you do it you will be
successful